Du bist zum zweiten Mal
Vater geworden.
Habt ihr euch überlegt,
ob man heute noch Kinder
in die Welt setzen darf? - Nein.
Wir haben uns überlegt, ob wir uns
noch ein Kind antun wollen,
weil es streng ist.
Aber nicht, ob man das der Mensch-
heit antun kann oder dem Klima.
Ich verstehe gut, was du sagst.
Die Debatte ist speziell.
Aber es wird oft diskutiert:
Darf man Kinder haben?
Einerseits wegen des Klimawandels.
Andererseits gibt es Antinatalisten,
die sagen,
jemanden ins Leben zu bringen
sei problematisch,
weil das Leben an sich nicht gut ist.
Das ist eine extrem steile These.
Zu sagen:
Wenn man von einem Leben
die guten und schlechten Momente
anschaut, überwiegen die schlechten.
Es ist doch schwierig,
das auszurechnen.
Der antinatalistische Standpunkt
hat Vorläufer.
Buddha hat diese Idee auch.
Es geht darauf, ins Nirvana zu kommen
und aus dem Kreis der Wiedergeburt
rauszufinden.
Das heisst, dass Leben Leiden ist.
Schopenhauer mit seinem Pessimismus
hatte eine ähnliche Theorie.
Diese Sicht
ist mir eigentlich sehr sympathisch.
Echt?
Wenn ich
durch den Zürcher Hauptbahnhof gehe
und die rennenden Menschenmassen
sehe ...
Man kann sagen: Man ist unzufrieden,
bis ein Bedürfnis befriedigt ist.
Und dann kommt das nächste.
Das ist Schopenhauers Ansicht.
Das ist für mich plausibel.
Ich betrachte die Menschen von aus-
sen und frage mich, was sie da tun.
Trotzdem
gibt es auch schöne Momente.
Das Streben hat auch etwas Schönes.
Das Leben
ist nicht insgesamt negativ.
Ich auch nicht.
Bei einer Strassenumfrage würden
die meisten sagen, sie leben gerne.
Aber David Benatar,
ein südafrikanischer Philosoph,
der Antinatalist ist,
sagt, wir leiden alle
unter einer kognitiven Verzerrung
und blenden aus,
dass wir Liebeskummer haben werden,
unseren Job verlieren werden -
wir reden uns das Leben schön.
Das kann sein, dass das
ein Trick der Evolution ist,
damit wir uns nicht umbringen, weil
es sinnlos und unerträglich ist.
Ich bin mit der "Zäller Wiehnacht"
aufgewachsen.
Ein Lied heisst "Kei Muetter weiss".
Dieses Lied hat
eine tiefe philosophische Bedeutung.
"Kei Muetter weiss,
was ihrem Chind wird gscheh."
"Kei Muetter cha i d'Zuekunft gseh."
Man weiss nie, ob das Kind leiden
oder ein gutes Leben haben wird.
Und darum, sagen die Antinatalisten,
sei das Risiko zu gross.
Es ist noch nicht lange her, dass man
Frauen, die keine Kinder wollten,
sagte,
sie seien kalte Karrierefrauen.
Jetzt hat der Wind etwas gedreht.
Sicher nicht bei vielen,
aber bei einigen.
Es ist doch interessant,
wie sich das geändert hat.
- Es ist eine private Entscheidung.
- Hat es geändert?
Ich sprach mit der kanadischen
Schriftstellerin Sheila Heti.
Sie sagst,
sie selbst habe darunter gelitten.
Ihre Freundinnen auch.
Es gäbe einen sozialen Druck.
Man fragt Frauen Mitte 30,
ob sie Kinder wollen.
Man ist quasi eine halbe Frau,
wenn man keine Mutter ist.
Genau. Rebecca Solnit sagt,
es sei "die Mutter aller Fragen".
Es gibt keine Entscheidung im Leben,
die derart weitreichende Folgen hat.
Es verändert das Leben extrem.
Gleichzeitig
kann man es nicht vorwegnehmen.
Du weisst nicht, ob es dir gefällt
und wie es sich anfühlt.
Und du wirst sogar eine
andere Person. Es verändert dich.
Es ist so anstrengend. Aber diese
kleinen Füsschen und Händchen ...
Und sie riechen so gut. Muss man das
gegen das Klima gewichten?
Wie macht man das?
Der Babygeruch und diese kleinen
Füsschen, daneben der Klimawandel.
Diese Überlegung ist absurd.
Nichts schadet dem Klima so sehr
wie ein Kind, sagt man.
Man vergleicht natürlich
nicht die Füsschen mit dem Klima -
obwohl es auch
um den Fussabdruck geht.
Sie würden sagen:
Wir müssen gewisse Opfer bringen.
Das Klimaproblem ist eine Krise,
die uns existenziell
als Menschheit bedroht.
Deshalb müssen wir alle
Opfer bringen.
Man sollte vielleicht
nicht fünf Kinder haben,
sondern eines oder zwei.
Die Zahl,
die immer herumgeistert ...
58,6 t CO2 stösst man als Eltern pro
Jahr mehr aus, wenn man ein Kind hat.
Auf das Auto zu verzichten
würde 0,8 t C02 pro Jahr einsparen.
Auf Fleisch zu verzichten 2,4 t.
Es ist eine eindrückliche Zahl.
Man geht davon aus, dass man
die Klimaemissionen der Kinder
der eigenen anrechnen muss.
Und auch die Tatsache, dass
die auch wieder Kinder haben werden.
In den USA gibt es einen Verein:
Voluntary Human Extinction Movement.
Die Bewegung für das freiwillige
Aussterben der Menschheit.
Die gehen einen Schritt weiter.
Sie sagen,
die Menschheit sei so schlecht ...
Stichwort: Biodiversität.
Die Menschen zerstören den Planeten
und sind verantwortlich für Tierleid.
Darum wäre es freundlich von uns,
wenn wir uns motivieren würden,
freiwillig auszusterben.
Das Problem ist: Du weisst nicht,
was deine Kinder bewirken werden.
Vielleicht bringst du eine Greta
auf die Welt, die das Klima rettet,
die die Menschheit aufweckt.
Mir erscheint wichtig,
dass Kinderhaben auch heisst,
auf die kommenden Generationen
zu vertrauen.
Du hast von einer kleinen Familie
gesprochen: ein Kind oder zwei.
Aber nicht sieben.
Das ist eindeutig schlecht.
Es kommen nicht sieben Gretas
zur Welt und retten das Klima.
Wenn dir der Staat oder
die Weltgemeinschaft vorschreibt,
du darfst nur ein Kind
oder zwei haben ... - Aber ...
Ich weiss nicht,
ob so was philosophisch haltbar ist.
Man kann sagen,
aus utilitaristischer Sicht ...
Wenn man die Folgen und den Nutzen
für die gesamte Menschheit anschaut,
ist es vielleicht sinnvoll,
aber es ist ein Eingriff ...
Meiner Meinung nach
muss man zwei Dinge unterscheiden.
Einerseits die Frage,
ob der Staat eingreifen darf.
Da bin ich extrem zurückhaltend.
Wie du gesagt hast: Reproduktive
Freiheit ist extrem wichtig.
Also dass man selbst entscheiden
kann, ob und wann man Kinder möchte.
- Das wäre Chinas Ein-Kind-Politik.
- Wieso ist das per se schlecht?
Weil ich der Meinung bin, da geht es
um höchstpersönliche Interessen -
so würde man das juristisch nennen.
Du hast den Utilitarismus erwähnt.
Da liegt man sich in den Haaren.
Es gibt Utilitaristen, die sagen,
man solle auf Kinder verzichten.
Man rechnet nach,
wie stark sich der eigene
ökologische Fussabdruck vergrössert.
Andere behaupten genau das Gegenteil.
Sie sagen, man sollte
so viele Kinder wie möglich haben.
Denn jedes wird potenziell
ein so schönes Leben haben,
wird potenziell
so viel Gutes erleben.
Es geht beim Utilitarismus
ja immer darum,
die bestmöglichen Folgen
herauszuholen.
Wenn du nur ein Kind hast, kann nur
ein Kind ein schönes Leben haben.
Wenn du zwei hast, sind es zwei.
Aber die Wahrscheinlichkeit,
dass das Leben noch schön ist,
wenn alle sieben Kinder haben,
ist klein.
Warum glauben wir, dass ein Eingriff
in die reproduktive Freiheit -
und da geht es nicht um den Staat,
sondern um uns gegenseitig -
so absurd ist?
Wir finden es ja nicht zwingend
absurd, jemanden zu kritisieren,
weil er dreimal pro Jahr
zum Shopping nach New York fliegt.
Da muss man sich rechtfertigen.
Warum beim Kinderhaben nicht?
Ich glaube, weil es um eine Erfahrung
geht, die existenziell ist.
Ich will damit aber nicht sagen,
dass es bloss ein Trieb ist.
Wenn wir
von einem Trieb sprechen würden,
würden wir Frauen und Männer
diskriminieren,
die sagen, sie wollen das nicht.
Es muss darum gehen,
dass wir uns gegenseitig
existenzielle Erlebnisse
nicht verwehren dürfen.
Wenn dich dieses Thema interessiert:
Wir haben am philosophischen
Stammtisch darüber gesprochen,
ob man heute noch Kinder haben darf
oder ob es eine private Frage ist.
Und wir haben
mit Sheila Heti gesprochen.
Sie erzählt darüber,
wie schwierig es ist,
sich für oder gegen die Mutterschaft
zu entscheiden. Klick da!